so why did former president trump's  impeachment lawyers all leave on mass  and why can't he just use rudy well rudy  is a material witness to this  impeachment jay sekulow was  too smart to ruin himself over this  particular impeachment though he was  fine in the last impeachment well it  seems like the real problem is that real  lawyers don't like to lie either to  courts or to congress and they're  worried about their reputation former  president trump is basically toxic over  the capital insurrection and it seems  like trump wants to focus on this as his  primary defense that  he was justified in making all these  crazy statements and these lawyers just  aren't going to put up with that whether  it's for their reputation or because  it's completely illegal so i know what  you're thinking hopefully former  president trump will represent himself  yolo so subscribe or i'll see you in  court